6 15 on your Finally Friday what's cool
is cool well how about a pat on the back
and a push to the Future for the top
middle school spellers in the Clark
County School District
these six young men and women were
treated to lunch made and served by High
School culinary students over at the
East Career Technical Academy
stonix from the CCSD Student Activities
Department the first and second place
6th 7th and 8th grade spellers each
given plaques made for a perfect proud
family photo opportunity there you go
ask for tips to stay sharp on spelling
8th grader Isabelle from rogich middle
school said being a good reader helps
and she gave a shout out to her dad he
like gave me some like you know hard
words that he found to sell like while
we were like
eating dinner or something congrats to
all
from Belinda Brown the head of the state
spelling bee which is where these bright
students are headed in March
yeah along with dozens of others from
all over Nevada these kids are going to
find out which one of them will go on to
represent the Silver State at the
National Spelling Bee later this year
you know we always want to know what's
cool at school you got something let us
know cool at school under the Community
tab of our website or just email cool at
school at 8newsnow.com and again I
wanted to mention uh from Melinda Brown
the head of the state spelling Mission
hey if you know anybody with a lot of
money if someone is willing to sponsor
we could get a second Nevada student
sent to the National Spelling Bee okay
how much do they have to come up with I
didn't hear a number but you can get a
hold of Melinda Brown at the Nevada
state spelling bee which by the way the
pronouncer for the Nevada state spelling
bee yes is our good friend Kendall Timmy
okay
come on John pull out your checkbook
write a check get a second student
Mega Millions oh yeah